[Applause]
hello welcome to our apartment please
come in
[Music]
please come in have a look
when you look out there it's one of the
best views of Hong Kong I claim it to be
you can see over there is our our small
beach where we can bring Gabriela every
weekend far the way you would see the
airport down there you can see the ships
running back and forth from n to Macau
let me introduce this this is Stefan
this is me and this is Gabriella
we have stuffers chinese name here
Stefan in Chinese please see you tighten
and then we got some accessory when we
go traveling this is from Bali ok kool
it's one of the most important parts of
our home that's our mini bar with
bottles from all over the world whenever
we go traveling we try to make a stop
somewhere in a duty-free shop so some
some nice whiskies from Scotland and
Ireland what is his name
discovery others friends
[Music]
I'm want our crisis is lining up Finn
Abbess at lysine over your money
Casca now HD how its computer
this is one of our decoration this is a
certified as a light wealthy and good
luck and good health or the family
[Applause]
thank you for visiting us bye-bye
you
[Music]